Briona is with us she's in Virginia hey
Brianna welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
I think you're taking my call
sure what's up so a little over a year
ago my husband I sold our first house
and moved across the country I'm kind of
in a rush and because of the timing of
things ended up in an epic we bought a
new home here ended up with a 30-year
FHA mortgage because we didn't have
enough for 20% down payment and I'm
integrated 5.12 to five good lord
yeah so actually right now as a last
week we were looking at refinancing and
started the application on that but then
we've been listening to you and kind of
cost and realize we actually just want
to get really serious with the baby
steps plan and right now we're at thirty
to thirty three percent of our take-home
pay on the mortgage and we're both
pretty strongly considering the idea of
just selling this house and moving to
buying something that's more affordable
for the baby steps with your 25% 15-year
mortgage guidelines
what's your household income base salary
like about bonuses and stuff is 178 178
yes four years and how much bonuses do
you usually get it would be for me that
I'd say this year and the next year's
would be between 10 to 20,000 before
test okay and what do you guys do for a
living I work for a tech company here
and he works customer support for
start-up company you work for a what
company that company yep
taxi easy eight I'm sorry I can't I'm
sorry
having trouble hearing okay all right
all right
[Music]
how old are you I'm 26
okay did you calculate the 33% with
bonuses or without range I think with I
think with with the bonus is about 30%
so the lowest it was with 30 on the
30-year mortgage yeah did you calculate
are you taking money out of your check
for 401ks and did you calculate that I
am and I know I did I believe I
calculated in fact yeah okay I don't
think you're as tight as you think you
are you're making a lot of money making
a couple hundred grand a year and say if
you don't like the house and you want to
move I'm okay but this house is not
killing you I would refinance it and
keep it oh yeah you're in an upward
trajectory on your income you're fine
you're at you're in you're in good
industries you're not going to be making
200 you're gonna be making 300 and and
yeah I'm thinking if you put your 4 I
see I'm talking when I talk about
take-home pay I don't talk about what
everything I'm talking about just after
taxes after proper tax withholding 25%
of your take-home pay not after money
coming out for a car payment over the
credit union not after money coming out
for child support not after money coming
out for 401k money coming out for taxes
what's left after tax take-home pay and
somewhere around 25% of that you're
gonna be a little bit over that when you
refinance on a 15-year and get that
interest rate down but not a ton you're
okay you're alright if you like the
house out state